This is Miss Germany.
In the election to Miss Germany,
I would like to explain 2 aspects of what Germany stands for
right now and where the problems lie.
This is Miss Germany.
What stands out as 1?
This is the sash.
The sash is not in black,
red,
gold.
And it shows the self-loathing that left-wing ideologues have against Germany.
You really rarely see the German flag in Germany and here,
too,
it turns out that the scherpe is no longer in black,
red, gold.
It shows the self-loathing of one's own country that
these left-wing ideologues have in Syria.
The 2nd important aspect is that our Miss Germany is actually
then also chosen to represent us Germany at Miss Universe.
I can't say anything against the lady now,
it's a normal pretty woman.
It somehow also shows the competitiveness of Germany,
because we will not be in competition with this Miss Germany at Miss Universe.